this is a production of Cornell
University
alrighty thanks everyone and thank you
for the lovely introduction it's such a
pleasure to be here speaking with
everybody today
um I joined plant Sciences back in
Spring of 2020. you can imagine that's
not a time when it was super easy to get
to know many of you although there's
some familiar friendly places in the
room so glad to see you here so I was
really excited for this opportunity to
share with you some of the research work
that I've been doing at Cornell not just
here in sips but also during my time in
entomology for those of you who are
um hemp Team Buddies there will
certainly be a little bit of hemp at the
end but you'll have to hold through what
we talk about a whole bunch of other
specialty crops here in the Finger Lakes
Region
so although I joined sips in 2020 I
first came to Cornell back in 2011 to do
my PhD with Greg Globe up here in the
top in entomology at the agritech campus
in Geneva New York I also had the
opportunity to work really closely with
Brian Danforth and members of his lab
here to develop molecular tools and use
phylogenies to understand
patterns and aggro ecosystems and also
to work really closely with Dr Katya
poveda here on the Ithaca campus and
when I finished my PhD I transitioned
into a postdoc in her lab before joining
you all here in the school of
Integrative plant Sciences as a sips
wide senior lecturer so during that time
I also had the luck to work with more
than 60 different farmer collaborators
all across the Finger Lakes region of
New York without whom none of them were
work that I'm going to present to you in
the next 40 minutes or so would have
been possible a lot of the motivation
for the kinds of questions I ask is
around creating uh solutions that
Growers have that balance agricultural
productivity with conservation of
biodiversity on working land so this
work would really not have been possible
without them and I'm incredibly grateful
to their mentorship and advice and
guidance and welcoming me onto their
Farms to do this kind of work
so is my title alluded to uh one of the
primary drivers of biodiversity loss
worldwide is land use change the
transition of natural habitats towards
agricultural uses which results not only
in a overall loss of the amount of
available habitat but also in a
fragmentation of the remaining natural
habitats that are left distributed
across these aggro ecosystems so in
terms of species that can influence
their ability to disperse or to colonize
or persist in these natural habitats and
when we add that up across many species
that influences the overall composition
of communities in agro-ecosystems
so as we move from Landscapes that have
more diverse mixes of land use to those
that tend to be more dominated by
agriculture we lose a few essential
resources that can help to support
beneficial insects that can be promoting
ecosystem services so we often see that
a transition from more naturally
dominated Landscapes or mixed-use
Landscapes to ones that are more simple
associated with a reduction in things
like floral resources which means a loss
of important pollen and nectar resources
for beneficial insects like bees as well
as parasitoid wasps alternative hosts
and prey at times when pests may not be
prevalent within cropping systems are
very essential for supporting beneficial
insects like natural enemies of crop
pests we also lose important Refuge
habitats so that could be Refuge from
things like pesticide applications but
it could also be things like Harvest or
tillage some of those big disturbances
that are associated with agricultural
habitats and of course also a loss of
important overwintering habitats that
allow these populations to persist
and so overall these changes in the
landscape result not only potentially in
a loss of important species Within These
ecosystems but also the key ecosystem
services that they provide we know that
wild bees for example are much more
abundant and provide better pollination
services on farms with Landscapes that
have high cover of natural habitat in
the surrounding landscape we also know
that natural enemies of our crop pests
tend to be more abundant more diverse
and have higher levels of activity
against pests in Landscapes that have a
higher level of natural habitat so
there's been a few studies that have
documented these in crop systems all
over the world mostly looking at really
highly agriculturally intensive
Landscapes so when I came here back in
2011 I wanted to understand whether
these patterns were also impact thing
Growers here in our relatively diverse
mixed-use Finger Lakes region in New
York state and I started working on this
question using strawberries as a focal
crop system to answer these questions so
many of you are probably much more
familiar with strawberry systems than
entomology groups that I tend to give
this talk to but just in case
strawberries here in New York state are
grown perennially they are grown in a
range of different kinds of production
systems so here in the middle we have an
example of matted row strawberries these
will flower and produce fruit generally
in June and in between the roads are
mulched with straw but we're also seeing
an increase in adoption by Growers of
plastic culture production as well as
day neutral strawberry plants so for my
initial work I focused just on farms
that were growing one cultivar one of
the most common ones in this region
Jewel and they were all using this
matted row style production but the big
key difference across all of our farm
sites that you can see here around the
Finger Lakes region is that we selected
Farms that span this gradient in the
amount of natural habitat present
surrounding that field site so in the
far example here we have a relatively
complex landscape so we have lots of
natural habitat interspersed with these
agricultural Fields the fields
themselves are kind of irregular in
shape there's lots of hedgerows or other
linear habitats like that riparian
buffer running through the fields and
the crops there are relatively diverse
in terms of their composition so there's
a lot of opportunity for resources to
occur spread across the distribution of
that landscape that would facilitate the
movement of beneficial insects from
those natural habitats into the crop
system
in contrast some of our Farms had much
more simplified Landscapes around their
focal field and so in this case we have
a farm that has almost entirely one
other crop type around it in this case
it was apples apples and strawberries
are grown commonly together on the same
Farms here in this region we have very
little natural habitat and a lot of very
regular structure to that habitat not a
lot of Natural Area remaining so one of
the first questions that we wanted to
understand with this cultivar Jewel that
was being grown on farms here in the
Finger Lakes is how much does it depend
on things like wild pollinators in order
to have a high level of crop
productivity so thinking about things
like fruit set for example and to do
that on each of the Farms we had plants
that were bagged which means they only
were exposed to their own pollen no
pollen that was coming in from insect
visitors we call that our
self-pollination treatment we also had
plants that were free and open to insect
visitation and ones that had
supplemental hand pollination added to
those and what we found across all of
our Farms is that there's some evidence
that this variety Jewel benefits from
pollination Services provided primarily
by wild bees which we found more than 80
species across all of our Farms we see
about a 40 percent increase in yield
when we compare those self-pollinated
fruits to fruits that were allowed to
have insect visitation when they were
flowering
however if we compare those to our hand
pollination treatment we found that we
still weren't able to achieve the full
potential suggesting that a lot of these
Farms had pollen limitation and when we
break down this contrast comparing open
and hand
across our sites so in this plot each
one of these bars is an individual Farm
site we see that just under half of our
Farms are experiencing significant
pollen limitation so that means the open
pollinated fruits are much smaller than
the hand pollinated fruits are across
those sites and when we look at those
the primary driver that we found to
explain that difference is of course the
number of B visits to those flowers
during the flowering period when we did
transects in those fields so sites that
had very low levels of visitation had
the greatest difference between their
hand pollinated and their open
pollinated fruit set but that difference
disappeared at the highest levels of B
visitation observed
unfortunately
what we also found is in these
relatively diverse wild bee dominated
communities they were lower not only in
abundance but also in richness a measure
of diversity at The Farms at sites that
were surrounded by high proportions of
Agriculture so as we increase the amount
of agricultural habitat at the one
kilometer scale around each field we see
a decline in both the abundance and the
richness of these on that farm
suggesting that these Farm sites are
more likely then to suffer from pollen
limitation so how about for pest control
then
to explore that question we focused
primarily on this one pest insect the
tarnished plant bug ligus lineularis and
our surveys found that this insect was
causing as much as 40 percent crop
damage across all of our Farms on a
given year
fortunately
there is a complex of both native and
introduced parasitoid wasps in the 70s
the USDA went to Europe found the
European tarnish plant bugs parasitoids
and introduced them into the U.S to
control this native pest insect it's a
fun time for classical biological
control during that period subsequently
we saw Regional levels of tarnish plant
bug populations decline meaning that
these insects were quite successful
overall in controlling the pests but
these parasitoid wasps require a bunch
of things like nectar in order to help
them produce eggs that they then
overposite into the nymphs of our
tarnished plant bugs which are the ones
that are causing damage on the
strawberry fruits so potentially sites
that have more floral resources as well
as more connectivity between those
floral resources and our agricultural
Fields May potentially have higher
levels of parasitism rates and to detect
those we sampled nymphs from all of the
fields across our range of sites and we
used some molecular tools to identify
the DNA of the parasitoid wasps so we
could determine which species had
attacked the nymphs and the overall
proportion parasitism at a site so as
soon as those larvae that are inside of
the developing nymphs reach a particular
developmental stage they erupt out of
the nymph's body as a brand new wasp and
that nymph perishes
what we found was that at very small
spatial scales around our Fields higher
levels of natural habitat were
associated with an increase in
parasitism rates and the small spatial
scale potentially makes them sensier
because these are very tiny little
parasitoid wasps they're probably not
moving very great distances across Farm
landscapes in contrast
higher levels of natural habitat around
farms at much larger spatial scales
double the scale was associated with a
reduction in tarnish plant bug abundance
which could be due to the parasitoid
populations having a top-down effect
where they're suppressing pest
populations but doesn't necessarily rule
out that tarnished glint bugs also maybe
suppressed by other factors at the
landscape scale so it may be that having
a higher diversity of different plants
means that tarnish plant bugs are using
those weedy resources may maybe more so
than in the Strawberry Fields
either way
thumbing up what we found in this first
initial study was that Farms that are
surrounded by high proportions of
Agriculture with low amounts of natural
habitat had fewer bees and overall
greater likelihood of pollen limitation
and
less pest control so what would a grower
do what are their options if they find
themselves in one of these
agriculturally intensive Landscapes one
idea that's been proposed is to augment
the resources that are available in
these Landscapes using things like
Wildflower plantings there are two
programs sponsored by the federal
government the conservation Reserve
program and the equip program that will
actually subsidize the establishment of
these conservation plantings on Farmer
lands and so it would be good to know
how effective they are potentially
solving some of these problems by
providing that Refuge flow resources
alternative hosts and overwintering
sites that could be absent
not all good news though because
unfortunately there was a proposed
Theory at the time that we undertook
this study that suggested that the
effectiveness of adding something like a
wildflower strip one of these
agro-environmental schemes should depend
on the landscape that you put it in
so on the far example here in a cleared
highly agricultural landscape if you
establish a wildflower planting in the
middle of one of these Landscapes you're
not very likely to have an overall
positive effect either in terms of
biodiversity conservation or potential
benefits to ecosystem Services the
reason for that is that this landscape
is very unlikely to have a pool of
beneficial insects that could move into
your Wildflower planting be supported
and then spill back over into your crop
and in fact if there are things like
wild bees or natural enemies existing
already in that landscape they probably
are pretty tolerant and will be able to
persist in that landscape without this
additional resource added
at the far end of things in really
complex Landscapes if we were to add a
wildflower planting in the center of
this landscape here it would likely be a
drop in the bucket in terms of the
overall amount of resources that we are
adding into that landscape there's
already a really diverse mix of
different land uses present here lots of
natural habitat that facilitate that
movement of beneficial insects across
that natural crop boundary so adding a
wildflower resource strip here is not
again going to do very much to increase
your overall amount of biodiversity or
the services on your farm but it's
really this Goldilocks zone in the
middle here where we have what we would
call intermediate Landscapes and in fact
this hypothesis was termed the
intermediate landscape hypothesis which
suggests that only in these Landscapes
where we have some amount of natural
habitat but adding resources in would
meaningfully increase the availability
of important resources for beneficial
insects and furthermore May influence
their movement from natural habitat
fragments into the crop habitat where
they can potentially provide ecosystem
services so the time that we started out
looking at this this had just been
proposed as a hypothesis and so one of
the studies that I wanted to undertake
was to evaluate whether or not these
Wildflower strips would provide
important services for Growers and also
if there was some landscape context
dependency to their services we wanted
to take questions
we are doing it's unusual but you can do
it if you want I'm happy to take a
question
where does that make I'm super glad you
asked that so for people who aren't
always thinking about these landscape
scale patterns so but what I showed you
before things that are at quite a small
scale so just 500 meters from the edge
of a field for example and often it'll
depend on what we know about How likely
in any particular organism is to travel
or to be influenced by the other
habitats around them so often when we
say landscape we mean sort of like this
amorphous thing that's dependent on the
particular organisms that we are talking
about so there was no strict
scale that was associated with this
original hypothesis but because we had
done some earlier work and found that at
least four biological pest control and
for pollinators that scales somewhere
between 500 and one kilometer were
seeming to be the most predictive of
responses within our community that's
what we used for our study going forward
so we picked out 12 farms and on each of
these Farms we established two
experimental strawberry planting so
planted out plug plants in the first
year and at one of the plantings on each
Farm we had a border row of native
perennial wildflowers we established
these from plugs because it was a PhD in
our life so many years to do that
Growers would normally establish these
from seed and even then it's quite
expensive to establish one of these
habitats part of the reason why we have
these large subsidy programs overall so
we put these in as pug plants we worked
with the plantsmen to collect local Eco
types of a lot of these plants and then
get them established on our Farms we
selected species that had a range of
broad Bloom times so that hopefully we
would be able to support all of our
beneficial insects across the entire
span of a season here
and so when it came to our response
variables again what we were looking for
was crop visitation as well as our
biological pest control and yield and in
all cases you're going to see a lot of
thoughts that look like this I'm going
to walk you through them first so we
have the proportion of natural habitat
here and this is actually at the 750
meter scale so it's intermediate between
those two time points and the points
that will appear on here are going to
represent the difference between our
control site and our Wildflower site so
any points that are above the stashed
line means that Wildflower plantings had
more in this case more bee visitation
than the control sites did
so I'll show you our data for B
visitation and what we found the first
thing that pops out is this really nice
example of what we were hoping to see
which is this curve showing
effectiveness
here we actually had some sites at very
low amounts of natural habitat that had
fewer fees in their plantings with
wildflowers compared to our control
sites potentially indicating that our
Wildflower plantings may be competing
with the crop for pollinators in
Landscapes where pollinator populations
are overall relatively low and it was
only in this narrow range of about 35 to
55 percent natural habitat in the
surrounding landscape where we saw any
benefit of having Wildflower plantings
for bee Services overall and even then
it took us three years
to see those effects so we established
in year one and then this is year two
three and four of this study so in the
first two years we really didn't see any
benefit at all independent of landscape
context of adding in these Wildflower
plantings and probably part of the
reason for that is because we chose to
use these perennial wildflowers they
took until this final year to really get
going and get established and have a
good stand establishment in that small
Wildflower plot but it could also been
population level responses of our
pollinator communities which take
multiple years if there is a benefit in
terms of increased resources in year one
that might mean that there's a higher
level of bee larvae that are produced in
that year which then would emerge in the
subsequent year so it took us a while to
see this context dependent benefit
in terms of our
effect on pests we really saw no benefit
at all of planting these Wildflower
strips in fact we saw a cost associated
with putting these in Landscapes that
had the fewest the lowest amount of
natural habitat available so in these
landscapes there were more pests
art sites that had a wildflower planting
which is definitely not what we were
hoping to see and part of that may have
to do with the specific biology of the
pests that we're working with tarnish
plant bug is not just a pest of
strawberry it's a pest of many other
crops it's a huge generalist it will eat
nearly anything that it can stick its
proboscis into and so in the last year
of the study we looked at all of the
plants that were showing up in our
Wildflower margins and we surveyed them
for how many pests they were supporting
versus how many of our pollinators they
were contributing and there was a few
really important plants especially those
that are opportunistic weedy species
like this Daisy fleabane up here origin
that supported really high levels of
tarnish plant bug with contributing
basically nothing to promote beneficial
insects so management of these plantings
and the plants that were in within the
strips could actually have an important
role in shifting that cost and balance
but at least in our study we didn't find
any benefits in terms of biological
control
and so for yields looking at uh for
example fruit damage we see that these
Landscapes over here that had the
highest amount of pests also have the
highest amount of damage they have the
app on average the smallest
fruits here and there's only in terms of
yield benefits
basically no benefit to adding a
wildflower planting onto these Farms so
this is kind of discouraging news since
we had seen such a great effect in terms
of our bee visitation response so we
were wondering whether this was true
maybe in other crop systems and to
answer that question I teamed up with
Steve McCullough you can see here who
was a PhD student at Virginia Tech and
had just finished collecting a huge data
set covering not just strawberry but
three other crops as well and his design
used this Farm level analysis so in this
case he had 22 Farms spread all the way
across the Eastern Shore that included
both Maryland and Virginia half of those
Farms so the Farms that have a triangle
here were control Farms so unlike my
study where I had two plots relatively
close to each other on the same farm he
had entirely different farms and in his
Farms that had a a wildflower planting
he had a full-size CRP for equip
planting that he was working with so
potentially much bigger ability to
detect true differences if indeed they
do occur between sites that have these
plantings and not his site also spanned
a gradient in terms of the surrounding
landscape complexity and so what we
decided to do is attack this data using
something called a structural equation
model these kinds of statistical
approaches allow us to capture the
relatedness among multiple variables
that we were collecting so looking not
only at the effect of these biodiversity
practices like conserving natural
habitat around the farm or adding a
wildflower planting into these
intermediate variables here so things
like biological pest control or
pollination and then how they casted
down to affect important response
variables like crop yield and so in this
case we could see a direct effect if for
example natural habitat increased the
rate of pollination which in turn was
associated with an increase in the
proportion of crop yields that would be
an indirect positive effect but we might
also see a direct effect not going
through this path but just directly
leading from natural habitat to
marketable crop yield if there was some
other variable that we had not measured
or if the way that we measured these
variables for example was not accurately
reflecting their true impacts on crop
field we did
um four different structural equation
models one for each one of these crops
so I'm showing you these here you have
to worry too much about following any of
the lines I will pull out the highlights
for you so the first in thinking back
about our initial question about
Wildflower plantings if we look here
and see the Wildflower planting effect
and when these two lines meet that means
that there is an interaction the effect
of wild flowers on whichever response
variable that they're leading to here is
mediated by the landscape and in several
of our crops we did find evidence that
when Wildflower strips had an effect it
was dependent on the landscape context
and in one case for strawberries there
was a direct positive effect where the
Wildflower plantings
increased the level of damage from
drosophila Suzuki the spotted Wing
drosophila in our strawberry plantings
so overall
the effects of Wildflower plantings were
fairly inconsistent across all crops
some crops like collards for example had
no effect of Wildflower plantings at all
and when they were present they were
frequently landscape contacts dependent
in ways that were not consistent even
across the different pest groups that we
were looking at
what did come out as fairly consistent
across all four crops is either a direct
or an indirect effect at natural of
natural habitat on marketable crop yield
and in fact across all four crops we saw
the most responses when we were looking
at the amount of marketable crop yield
so grade one classification of the yield
in any one of those four crops was much
more sensitive to all of these variables
and seemed consistently to have positive
responses
still not great news though for our
farmers who find themselves in
simplified agricultural Landscapes it
again really looks like
doing these conservations small-scale
on-farm conservation practices may not
be the solution to that particular issue
so what could farmers actually do
they might choose to try to manage the
crops that co-occur on their Farm to try
to support ecosystem services that are
perhaps in the case of Apple a mass
flowering crop that may draw in lots of
pollinators which could then spill over
into later blooming strawberries so we
might use that distribution of different
crops on a farm to try to use that as a
way to supplement the resources that are
available to Insects on those farms and
that could could be good but it could
also work against a grower so for
example if we have strawberries blooming
at the same time as a mass flowering
crop like Apple
Apple has really large very abundant
flowers and may actually draw
pollinators away and make compete with
strawberry for crop pollinators but if
we get the timing right which is a
variable that depends really strongly
not only on pulse of our selection but
on weather patterns which are becoming
even more variable across years we might
see this relationship where Apple blooms
first and then strawberry comes online
and we could see a higher likelihood of
facilitation where apple trees are
supporting the pollinators that would
then go on to visit strawberry so that's
what we decided to explore whether or
not that was true and to do that we
first had to characterize the pollinator
communities of both crops
which is what this network is here so
each one of these blue circles is a
different wild bee species the nodes
here represent strawberries and apple
and all of these gold circles are the B
species that are shared between these
two crops so we have substantial overlap
in the pollinator community and the size
of the circle here is how abundant that
bee is in both of those crops combined
so looking at that set of gold species
we can see that it makes up not only a
lot of the overall species but those
that are most abundant between our two
crops so to answer our question about
the timing of Bloom and how that
influences the likelihood for
facilitation or competition we again set
out
um Sentinel strawberry plants and we
used bee bowls to sample our pollinator
community on a series of farms all
across the Finger Lakes Region again but
we selected Farms this time that had
varying amounts of Apple cover
surrounding that strawberry field and we
put out our sampling arrays at early
Apple Bloom Peak and then in late Apple
Bloom to measure how that overlap
temporally In Bloom would influence the
dynamic and then at each time that we
were out we did some surveys to look at
the amount of Apple Bloom in the
landscape
and what we found in terms of B
visitation at least is that early in
Apple Bloom there was a marginal
negative effect of having higher cover
and Bloom of apple orchards surrounding
the strawberry field on the number of
bees that we collected in those b-balls
that became much stronger and
significant at Peak Apple Bloom but then
started to turn upwards after Apple
Bloom supporting this idea that
potentially having these overlapping
Bloom periods having crops that are
diverse across the landscape could
potentially act as a way to support
these beneficial insect communities and
this is not something that's just true
for these perennial crops which honestly
are very hard to shift in terms of
flowering time but could also be true
for emerging crops like hemp one of my
undergraduate students when I was in the
poveda lab Nate flicker whose picture
here was really interested in
understanding the insect communities of
emerging crop in this region hemp and so
he surveyed pollinator communities to
try to characterize what bees were
present there relative to the bees that
were providing very important ecosystem
services in other crops one thing he
noticed is that hemp is flowering at a
point in the mid-summer season when we
have very few other floral resources
available for bees so even in natural
habitats there's very little floral
resources in that June July period
what he found is a relatively diverse
bee Community not as quite as many bees
as we would get an apple or strawberry
dominated by the honeybee but also with
16 other species of wild bees
many of whom are actually very important
pollinators of other specialty crops so
we drew studies that had surveyed bee
communities from these other specialty
crops in the region and looked at the
overlap in the hemp B Community compared
to these other specialty crops like
apple or strawberry which it shares
about 25 percent of its overall
pollinator Community with or even crops
that are blooming at a similar time like
tomato and also not providing any nectar
resources
we mapped those out in a network
thinking and what you will hopefully see
in a minute there we go is that all of
those species oops so far well anyway
all the species that are present in hemp
are all Polymers of other crops there's
no bees that are unique to hemp meaning
that it can potentially support really
important pollinators of other crops in
this region but of course
it's not all good news these crops might
be supporting bees but they are
certainly also supporting pests so if we
want to think about using crop diversity
as a way to promote beneficial insects
we also need to be really aware of all
of these other pests that are located
within that system and so for the past
two years I've been working with Marion
zuffel and New York State IPM to
understand the pest insect Community
that's associated with hemp almost none
of them are unique to hemp some of them
are big pests of other specialty crops
growing within this region I've also
been taking images of leaves to build a
diagnostic library that Growers can use
to help identify different kinds of
insect damage that are showing up in
this crop even when the insects
themselves are not present and my
students have also been contributing to
generating knowledge that Growers can
use the hemp production systems class
that I teach every fall Bill Miller came
in and gave a great Hands-On activity in
that class where we evaluated different
propagation methods so looking at
different substrates different hormone
treatments different cultivars how all
of that influence rooting success as
well as the quality of those rooted
cuttings and the students were actually
able to not only set up this large
experiment but collect the data and uh
two of The Graduate students in that
class have written that up to be
included in our upcoming uh New York
State hemp production manual that's led
by my colleague at Harvest New York Dr
Daniela Vergara
so I think I will leave it here um and
thank everyone especially the folks on
the hemp team who have welcomed me here
for the past two years and I will take
some more questions
so we go to Geneva for questions first
you hi
um Heather great talk thank you so much
this was super informative
um I'm just I'm kind of trying to wrap
my head around this information
I I visit a fair number of strawberry
Growers who are interested in uh
encouraging national natural pollination
through planting wildflowers and it
sounds like if they have that
intermediate level of uh habitat
diversity then wildflowers would
actually be helpful
um for them but can you help me figure
out
how I would determine whether a habitat
had like low intermediate High
uh habitat diversity
yeah so to evaluate that and maybe I'll
repeat the question in case there's
anybody you didn't hear how do we
actually evaluate landscape context when
we're talking about making
recommendations to Growers so if you
think there's a grower who's excited
about Wildflower strips and you want to
let them know like oh you might be like
you're in the golden zone for making for
this will work but you know maybe not I
would actually say generally even in the
best landscape I probably would not
recommend planting Wildflower plantings
just because of the risk of spillover of
those most important pests like ligus is
so high we really didn't see an overall
benefit in terms of yield I think
Growers I would encourage them to think
more broadly about other integrated Pest
Management tools that they could use in
controlling their pests that could
benefit their bee populations or to
conserve natural habitats or plant other
crops that can provide resources that
aren't as likely to be also so a source
of pest populations but if they are
excited about it and they're able to get
a CRP or equipped subsidy to establish
those on their farms and you want to let
them know about the landscape there is a
site that's hosted by Nas called
cropscape where you can go in and look
at the land use and land cover of any
particular site there's also a new tool
that will be coming online fairly soon
called beescape which allows you to put
in an address of a site and get an
estimate of the amount of floral
resources and it builds the buffers in
for you it does a lot of all that behind
the scenes work that I would normally be
doing in a GIS so I can send you that
the information for that beescape
thank you
yes
um I'm going to take a Ithaca question
um is there maybe students first
um
the uh location or the way the design of
a white flower meaning like a belt or a
pen or dispatch would uh affect the year
or with the best
yeah so the question is about the
placement how does the placement of
these plantings influence their overall
costs or benefits to Growers or benefits
to biodiversity and we chose to put them
on the border of our small strawberry
flops and that was simply because that's
the main way that Growers seemed to be
implementing those our plantings were
quite small so putting them into the
middle of the crop for example wouldn't
have really made a huge amount of
difference it would have been just a few
meters and would have made it much more
challenging to manage weeds within our
crop system itself but one thing I
didn't talk about today what I think
it's really really important to think
about the spatial configuration of these
Wildflower plantings is that these are
really artificial habitats that we are
creating on farms there's no natural
area that would have this mix even of
native perennial Wildflower plants that
bloom contain for the entire season
that's very artificial and what we
actually find is that when bees are
visiting these Wildflower plantings that
have these Ultra Rich amount of floral
resources that are blooming across the
entire season that they spread pathogens
like wildfire in there so we evaluated
the bee community that was present in
those fields and found that there was a
very high level of pathogen prevalence
so I think actually if I could redo this
study what I might do is think more
about patchy distribution of those
floral resources across the farm not
concentrating them all into just one
region on the farm
is that where you talk about pathogens
pathogens of the bees so in particular
for bees one of the major drivers of
pollinator population declines is the
spread of emerging pathogens often those
that are associated with managed bees
like honeybees or managed bumblebee
species and those show up
in much higher prevalence in a
artificial Wildflower planting than they
would in an old field for example
yeah related to that have you do you
know about research that
[Music]
um
covers Woody species like native Woody
species plantings more of a heterose
situation
um there's certainly a lot of benefits
of hedgerows especially in areas where
there's a lot more thought about
protecting and conserving riparian areas
like California that have shown huge
benefits of hedgerows for these same
kinds of services but they're not always
the most practical for Growers to
establish or manage and so we looked at
these more herbaceous species but
certainly you could get equivalent if
not better levels of services from these
more perennial habitats that are even
less exposed to disturbance
Justine did you have a question my
question was just what was the photo on
your title slide oh that is an aerial
image of Cueva Spain which is a fruit
growing like tree fruit growing region
it has a beautiful Contour plantings I
spend way too much time looking at
Google Earth of random places yeah
source of pollen when you did the soft
pollinations with that self pollen from
the strawberry variety itself so we
enclosed our plantings in this like tool
mesh so it could have been wind
pollination coming from other cultivars
that were present or you know other
Jewel plants that were present on the
farm when we did hand pollination we
hand collected anthers from primary
Jewel flowers and collected that pollen
in the lab and then took it out to the
field and paint brushed it onto our
plants but the self pollination as well
as the open and actually even some of
the pollen that came from hand because
they weren't bagged certainly could have
been from other cultivars the reason I
ask is there's some evidence especially
what I'm saying pollen from a different
variety actually yeah and that would
actually show a greater impact of your
pollinator than doing the hand polish
absolutely so what Marvin was just
offering is that there's been a I think
maybe two or three studies now
especially for strawberry that have
shown that when you have particular
combinations of the pollenizer and the
receiver cultivar that you can get
better fruit set from those combinations
and that was very likely at play in our
system we just weren't able to control
for that in our study but would be
another reason potentially why
diversifying at the farm scale not just
crops but also cultivars could be
beneficial in terms of the level of
services
yeah forgive me if I haven't formulated
this question very well but
um when I look at I guess from an
ecology standpoint
where we're lacking or where we're
taking a lot of agricultural land from
which bio if you like the plates right
from Manitoba all the way down to Kansas
Oklahoma and as we take more and more
away we're losing more and more of that
biodiversity which I assume is probably
a pretty big pollinator habitat
um have we crossed or do you foresee
some sort of ticking point in which
increasing acreage is only diminishing
returns
um there has actually been a really nice
study recently that was published on
this looking at where across the U.S
we're seeing the greatest transition of
natural habitats towards agricultural
areas and it certainly is in the Upper
Midwest and Plains region overall most
of the land that is being transitioned
tends to be marginal in terms of its
agricultural productivity so we're not
expected to get great gains from
transitioning that habitat and in fact
that is some of the habitat that is most
critical for for supporting groups of
organisms not just insects but also
things like Prairie Grouse for example
that are known to be in Decline so one
thing that I will say often as landscape
ecologists use is primarily these linear
models we're not always looking for
these threshold type effects where maybe
everything is all great until we get
beyond that 35 percent natural habitat
cover threshold and I think that is
something that we'll probably start to
see more of to understand what is the
the Tipping Point overall
where it's not too complex not too
simple but it's a research into what can
be done for those areas that are so lack
handed any transplant kind of wouldn't
seems
so I think there are
um that's an area where managing the
crop diversity probably has the highest
level of potential if you are a farmer
that finds themselves in one of these
more simplified agricultural Landscapes
especially if you can't always control
what's going on in the area around your
farm you can absolutely control what's
happening within your farms and I think
there's actually a really great example
of this here in the Finger Lakes
Elderberry Pond Farm if any of you know
that farm they are situated in a
relatively simple landscape they are
just north of Canandaigua then no
they're they're in Auburn sorry they're
just north of Auburn
um pretty simple corn soy wheat
landscape around them but they have
invested over the long term like the
past 40 years in developing all of these
systems and manage their Farms not using
per se things like Wildflower plantings
that help to support eco system services
and they have actually a really healthy
and abundant bee population on that farm
and relatively good biological control
there as well
okay well thank you well we'll still be
around if you want to um uh ask her any
more questions thank you so very much
thanks everyone
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu